[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
bien
y
me levanto cada mañana
y a través de mi ventana por el cielo
brilla el sol
soy una de millones de jornadas empieza
la caravana el día y ya comenzó
somos semilleros de ilusiones y aunque a
veces nos perdemos sin saber a dónde ir
[Música]
el viento allá afuera sólo espera que
abramos nuestras alas pues nos quiere
repartir
como el girasol que espera sol cada
mañana y me importa si una nube no lo
deja amanecer
mira girasol
en busca de los
quien fuera como el girasol
ah
bailemos riamos con el fuego ahora
hacemos la esperanza con los ritmos del
amor
pura vida corre en nuestras venas
nuestras voces consignas del norte del
corazón
como el girasol que espera el sol cada
mañana y no importa que una nube no lo
deja manera
mira girasol
en busca de luz
que fuera como el girasol
lo siento no ser un solo corazón
y aunque todo es sostenido siempre
empiezo con colo colo
yo
siempre pienso
[Música]
siempre
es triste que dar un besito para ver su
perjuicio aunque para eso no tenga
siempre pienso
[Música]